seeing people not get opportunity that
they work for and deserve because they
can't afford it it's just something I
can't stand for my name is Christopher
gray I am the founder and CEO of Scala
and I am 24 years old I come from a
low-income background and my mom must
withdraw right after recession so we
didn't have a lot of money in schools
weren't giving as much age of high
achieving but I mean I had to really
either choose from finding money go for
college or not going to college at all
so took us seven months backing board to
library looking a bunch of different
websites that gave me a bunch of scam
things I didn't know so it took a while
but I ultimately found a good number of
them and I end up winning most of it and
I spent around two or three years
helping other people try to do the same
realize that the hardest part about
getting money for college is finding it
so I knew I had to create a solution to
to really solve that problem really when
I started school I didn't I love the
extra plan I started this I just want to
make an app to make my to make helping
people a lot easier then I realized this
is a really big issue on a national
skills and I wanted to make it
sustainable
I went on a loan shark tank actually on
February 2015 and what happened was that
I even started the biggest fight in
Shark Tank history I got a deal with
Damon and Laurie and Mark Cuban Robert
Herjavec and kevin o'leary walked off
the stage they were mad because Laurie
and Damon gave me all person quickly and
out the first time I saw it is I was
actually at my watch party so my film
that for an hour you probably saw seven
minutes of that and after Shark Tank
things just skyrocketed I was number one
in the entire app store both iPhone and
Android for almost a month we have done
guilty for white house we've done deals
with cities gunapp with their students
states so it's been an incredible
opportunity and Damon Laurie have been
really helpful and really moving our
company forward we've helped students
right now rate over 20 million dollars
in this is what we've tracked we just
only a little over a year old
you